the ocean is facing an existential
crisis
headline news focuses on plastic
pollution but another threat lurks
beneath the surface
if you look in the water there's almost
nothing there
parts of the ocean are dying
these so-called dead zones are starved
of oxygen
killing marine life
fishing communities around the world are
suffering the consequences
and the problem starts with chemical
pollution on land
it is our responsibility as farmers to
make sure that we're not impacting
people downstream
turkey is one of europe's holiday hot
spots
33 million tourists travel to the
country each year
but this year the sea view from istanbul
looks different
raw sewage entering the sea of mamara
has led to a surface of sludge
in turkey a slimy floating mass of
yellowish white sea slime
scientists call it mucilage but many
locals know it as
it's killing wildlife for fishermen the
filth is fouling their boats and killing
their catch
[Music]
is threatening the only livelihood
they've ever known
[Music]
like others in their community they have
been unable to fish
when he does make it out to sea
his luck doesn't fare much better
the fishermen know that sewage is only
part of the
snot is a symptom of a much bigger
threat
the ocean supplies at least half of the
earth's oxygen
when algae photosynthesize they provide
oxygen in the process
but in polluted water algae can grow out
of control
sometimes releasing sea snot
algal blooms provide food attracting
more fish
and wherever there's a crowd
there's waste
this is decomposed by bacteria at the
bottom a process which uses up a lot of
oxygen
to make things worse the algae
eventually dies too
adding even more waste for the bacteria
to decompose
this severely reduces oxygen levels in
the water
creating desert-like dead zones
the deep south of america home to the
gulf of mexico
here lies the second largest dead zone
in the world
to date more than four million acres
have become uninhabitable for most
marine life
[Music]
if you go diving in the water or look in
the water
there's almost nothing there
denise breitbart has been monitoring the
health of the ocean for decades
she leads a group of scientists formed
by the un to tackle the problem of dead
zones
[Music]
if you can't breathe nothing else
matters and fish and shellfish and all
these animals that we really value
depend on oxygen in the water just like
we depend on oxygen in the air this is
one of the craziest things i've seen in
my life
just massive amounts of fitters
for fish unable to flee the lack of
oxygen can prove fatal
mass fish kills regularly wash up on
shores surrounding the gulf
lining beaches from florida
to texas
and the problem is spreading
low oxygen zones in the open ocean have
been identified around the world since
the 1960s these areas have increased by
roughly the size of the european union
more than 500 low oxygen sites have also
been identified in coastal areas
but what's driving this devastation
so nutrient pollution comes from a wide
range of human activities it's
fertilizer from our lawns it's
fertilizer from agricultural fields
it's nitrogen produced by power plants
and cars and it's from sewage and septic
systems
here's how it works
nutrients like nitrogen and phosphorus
run off the land into the water
these nutrients feed the algae
creating the very blooms that suffocate
the sea
the main cause of the dead zone in the
gulf of mexico is the huge amount of
nitrogen and phosphorus coming down the
mississippi river from as far away as
the state of minnesota
ben dwyer is a fourth generation farmer
we got gertrude and
gertrude and patty gertrude and patty
he lives in rural minnesota in america's
corn belt how's it going here the annual
county fair is in full swing
[Music]
young lady does a good job let's give
all five a really good runner
you did good bud that was a really kind
of a proud dad moment watching madison
and sarah
show livestock this year hey good job
out there how was that
the farming community out here is really
kind of a close-knit really a tight
group of people we all grew up with one
another a lot of us go to the same
churches our kids go to school together
but farming isn't just the heart of the
community here it's the cornerstone of
the economy
most of our businesses out here are
either involved directly with farming or
supporting farmers
in minnesota alone 112 billion dollars
is generated through agriculture which
takes up over half the land
much of that is for crops to feed
livestock
and it's the fertilizer used on these
crop farms that winds up in the waters
it does bother me when i see some of the
consequences of what we're doing there's
a lot of room for improvement i think
when we look at what's happening down in
the gulf of mexico i think it should be
obvious to most of us that
it's not a sustainable path that we're
on
some 1.9 million tons of nitrogen and
more than 220 000 tons of phosphorus end
up in the gulf each year
the algal bloom created by these
nutrients appears on satellite imagery
each summer
urban waste from cities is partly to
blame
but it's farmland that is a dominant
pollutant here
with devastating consequences
peter thomas has spent years
investigating the impact of dead zones
on fish
so we're going to lower the oxygen
going into the tanks his findings sent
shockwaves through the scientific
community
one way to survive low oxygen is to
switch off reproduction
the ovaries and testes from these
hypoxic sites as soon as we opened up
the fish we could tell they were much
smaller
this is um
a very poorly developed ovary and this
is sometimes what we see in the low
oxygen zone
the microscope provided further evidence
of the harm caused by dead zones
there was a dramatic decrease
in the production of viable eggs
sperm counter male fish dropped too
but peter spotted something even more
bizarre
the females
showed evidence of masculinization
we found
sperm in the ovaries of some of the
females
in the gulf these intersex changes have
led to fewer female fish
all those species that can't reproduce
will disappear this effect will cascade
up the food web
and that of course will have a huge
impact on the ecosystems
but dead zones are not just threatening
the marine ecosystem
they contribute to the biggest
environmental problem of all climate
change
since the 1970s
more than 90 percent of excess heat
trapped in the atmosphere has been
absorbed by the ocean
this is causing sea temperatures to rise
by around 0.13 degrees celsius per
decade
and the problem is accelerating
as global warming heats the ocean dead
zones expand and that's yet even more
bad news for the planet
a big problem is that there's really a
vicious cycle here as oxygen in some
parts of the oceans and coastal waters
gets to zero or near zero
they then are producing greenhouse gases
scientists call this the feedback effect
of dead zones when oxygen levels in the
water drop really low bacteria have to
look elsewhere for energy
so they turn to nitrogen
the bacteria use up nitrogen
but in the process a greenhouse gas
called nitrous oxide is produced
eventually this makes its way to the
surface and into the atmosphere
where it contributes to global warming
the ocean produces around a quarter of
all nitrous oxide in the atmosphere
while n2o only accounts for around six
percent of greenhouse gas emissions its
potency is a real concern for scientists
we know nitrous oxide is laughing gas
but in fact is a really major
contributor to global warming that's 300
times as potent as carbon dioxide
around the world governments are going
to extreme lengths to cleanse the sea
from vacuuming up the sea snot to
farming nutrient-absorbing mussels
but tactics like these offer only
limited solutions
removing nutrients from the ocean and
coastal waters once they're in the water
is really problematic so really the
solution is to prevent the problem to
start with
but how do you convince those upstream
to care about what's happening
downstream
ready for some new grass guys
i know you are
ben is part of a landmark initiative run
by the state of minnesota
this incentivizes farmers to prevent
nutrient runoffs from their land here on
our farm we're choosing to do things a
little bit differently
instead of tilling and breaking up the
land ben plants his seeds directly into
the untilled ground
here the remains of smaller crops cover
and armor the soil so here we've got a
corn corn crop that we are going to
harvest for grain there's dead plant
material on the ground here left over
from the cover crop from this spring if
rain falls on on a no-till field the
water is just going to soak in nice and
easy
keeping our nutrients that we've put out
here right where they need to be versus
a tilled field where it's going to hit
the ground it'll start running down the
first hill that it finds and end up in
your local waterways
that is good who do you think is a
better swimmer see the two of you
oh no
my parents they live on a lake not too
far from here and my daughters one of
their very favorite pastimes that they
have is swimming
and playing in the lake we just wanted
to know that we were doing everything on
our part
and that requires some cutting-edge
technology
we'll get those soil tests back
which is what i have in front of me
right here
he maps the condition of his soil grid
by grid synthetic fertilizer is then
applied at different rates to match the
needs of the soil
you can see on here i've got it set at
20 gallons per acre i can just change
this button
right there and i'll switch to 15. we'll
use the gps to make sure that we apply
it exactly how we need it to be so we're
not over applying overlapping
as well as avoiding using excess
chemical fertilizer ben is growing
nitrogen producing plants an
environmentally friendly fertilizer
we've been getting between like 40 and
70 pounds of nitrogen out of that red
clovers we've been able to reduce our
our fertilizer cost by almost one-third
we would like to someday get our farm to
a point
where we are no longer applying
synthetic fertilizer and i do think it's
obtainable
since making these conservation changes
ben's bottom line is up
figures show that farmers certified with
minnesota's scheme earn more than those
who stick to conventional methods
but old habits die hard
i think one of the biggest holdbacks
that people have is there's so much
heritage in farming
so many of us grew up with our
grandparents and our dads plowing or
doing tillage it's hard to realize that
maybe there's a different way it's a big
jump and a leap of faith
so far only 1.6 of farms in minnesota
have been certified
but these farms have almost halved their
combined nitrogen loss
and prevented about 220 000 kilograms of
phosphorus from entering waterways that
wind up in the gulf
but that's a drop in the polluted ocean
the scale of this problem requires
global action across the farming
industry and beyond the consequences if
we don't do anything are really
severe
as the population grows nutrient
pollution is set to increase
along with global warming that means
more of the ocean will be lost to dead
zones
it means that fish will be displaced
fishing village is dependent on local
fisheries may find themselves in real
problems and there are probably problems
that we haven't even imagined yet
while the stakes are high
the solution is clear
we really know what needs to be done to
curtail land-based pollution
governments are already making pledges
to reduce the burning of fossil fuels
which would limit nitrous oxide in the
atmosphere from entering the waterways
but they need to take steps to tackle
the biggest culprits of nutrient
pollution in the ocean like banning raw
sewage from entering the sea and
imposing sweeping changes to decades-old
farming practices
individuals can act too buying food that
is produced sustainably
you can see at a young age there when
i was farming even before i was able to
go outside
it's grandpa yep there's grandpa
he's in that one too oh yeah
yeah we all did
you know we spend a lot of time talking
to farmers about conservation practices
we're hoping that if it can catch on
it's going to impact my daughters
their kids you know generations we don't
even know they're coming down the road
we're doing this for them the world
belongs to everybody and we don't want
to be the generation to ruin it we want
to be the ones to hopefully turn it
around and save it
i'm kate and i directed this film the
economist group has a new multi-year
initiative on pollution and ocean health
to find out more click on the link below
thanks for watching
you